pas possible c'est le sourire il ne faut
pas lâcher le sourire de jamais donner
l'impression à l'adversaire que tu as
été touché alors tu vas me poser par
exemple une question embarrassante et on
va voir comment un homme politique est
700 sortir dans ces moments là vas-y
alors comment comptez-vous diminuer le
prix du pain et augmenter le prix du blé
pour les agriculteurs voilà très bien
alors tu vois le sourire d'accord et en
même temps si tu pouvais entendre ma
voix intérieure que tu n'entends pas
bien sûr ma pensée c'est à la vache
ah le [ __ ] comment j'ai rien là-dessus
ils m'ont rien donné alors là il faut
qu'il s'en sorte alors pour s'en sortir
il faut qu'il réfléchisse et qui trouve
une réponse seulement il peut pas
s'arrêter comme ça tu vois il faut pas
rester là comme ça en train de dire
qu'est-ce que je vais faire d'autant
plus je dis alors j'attends votre
réponse
alors il y a un procédé qui est très
simple qui est très facile c'est des
phrases qui viennent automatiquement
comme ça ils pensent pas du tout à ce
qu'ils disent ils sont en train de
réfléchir alors ça donne à peu près ceci
monsieur Berto
vous m'avez demandé m'avez posé une
question à laquelle je m'attendais
d'ailleurs
et je dois dire que même si vous ne me
laviez pas posé c'est un problème que
j'aurais vraisemblablement abordé
moi-même parce que c'est un problème
extrêmement grave qui fait partir le
chrono extrêmement grave extrêmement
important et les Français et les
Françaises qui nous écoutent ont le
droit de savoir ce qu'il en est chrono
combien ça fait et ben ça fait
exactement 18 secondes 18 secondes tu
vois dans j'ai rien dit du tout 20
secondes mais j'ai réfléchi énormément
alors si ça ne suffit pas si ça ne
suffit pas j'enchaîne tu reprends non il
a cherché tu vois mais ça suffit alors
je voudrais si vous le permettez
Monsieur Berto répondre à cette question
avec infiniment de franchise en effet
c'est une question qui concerne au
premier chef la nation et même la nation
agricole qui nous écoute et qui est
inquiète et nous comprenons son
inquiétude donc vous m'avez posé cette
question très franchement et je vais
vous y répondre très franchement chrono
ça fait combien 50 secondes 50 secondes
pour ne rien dire j'ai toujours rien dit
mais il va falloir quand même à ce
moment là finissent par me donner une
réponse à partir d'un certain moment il
fallait falloir que je dise quelque
chose parce que sinon sa fille et ça
finirait par se voir même pour les gens
qui sont pas avertis alors là j'ai trois
solutions c'est-à-dire si j'ai une
réponse si pendant ces 50 secondes j'ai
réussi à trouver une réponse je te la
donne si j'ai pas réussi à trouver une
réponse j'ai deux solutions ou bien je
noie la question ou bien je te la
renvoie qu'est-ce que tu entends par là
alors on va démonter le problème bien on
va le mettre à plat pour que les gens
comprennent bien noyer la question on va
prendre un principe si tu veux tu vas
essayer de me poser une question qui n'a
pas trait à la politique ça va
simplifier le problème
par exemple
si on est tous les deux ou tous les
quatre en train de boire un verre tu me
dis Jean est-ce que tu penses qu'on a un
beau mois de mai je te réponds non en un
mois de mai dégueulasse il arrête pas de
faire froid il pleut sans arrêt bon ça
c'est un principe mais si je suis un
homme politique je ne peux pas te
répondre comme ça pourquoi parce que les
hommes politiques répondent jamais comme
ça ils répondent jamais franchement
directement donc tu vas me poser la
question et je vais voir je vais te
montrer comment la noix vas-y OK
est-ce que vous pensez que nous avons un
beau mois de mai
cher ami Monsieur Berto vous me demandez
si nous avons un beau moine il faut
toujours répéter la question tu vois ça
fait gagner 5 Slacks
vous le savez c'est pas à vous que je
vais la prendre la météorologie
nationale publie ses statistiques
officielles depuis 1885 je ne voudrais
pas vous accabler de chiffres en général
quand ils disent qu'ils vont pas vous
être laver les chiffres c'est le moment
où il profite pour vos enfiler un paquet
je ne voudrais pas vous accablé de
chiffres mais depuis 1885 la France a eu
des très beaux mois de mai des mois de
mai extrêmement chauds et extrêmement
ensoleillé je vous en citerai
quelques-uns mais 1896 mai 1902 mais
1908 et mai 1924 et puis nous avons eu
des mois de mai très froids et très
pluvieux par exemple mai 1920 mai 1944
et mai 1905 a été pratiquement glacial
alors je vous répondrai ceci par rapport
au très beau mois de mai que nous avons
eu le mois de mai nous vivons
actuellement est un mois de mai en effet
médiocre mais par rapport au très
mauvais
[Musique]
un autre truc c'est la courtoisie bon la
courtoisie par exemple je vais te dire
je ne vous attaque pas personnellement
monsieur Berteau vous êtes un homme
courageux et vous avez eu je le
reconnais d'ailleurs des résultats bon
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que comment tu
te sens à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que tu
me fais plaisir tu es gentil avec moi tu
dis des choses aimable alors je suis
content tu n'as pas du tout l'habitude
de débat politique parce que il faut
bien se dire dans un débat politique dès
qu'il y a une gentillesse la vacherie
est derrière immédiatement tu vois
d'ailleurs tu as qu'à les regarder dans
les débats politiques quand il y en a un
des deux qui commencent à être gentil
l'autre et comment savoir un visage
inqui en disant qu'est-ce qui va
m'arriver derrière ça tu vois alors il y
a supposons que on est tous les deux et
que tu as envie de me dire dans un des
batholiques je sais pas moi que par
exemple que j'ai l'air complètement
abruti comment tu vas t'y prendre
cher ami je vous trouve l'air
particulièrement abruti alors ça c'est
pas possible non plus ça c'est pas
possible parce que d'abord tu vas te
mettre les Français à dos les moins
c'est même pas qu'on soit grossier donc
il faut s'y prendre autrement il y a une
manière d'envelopper le paquet alors si
moi je veux te dire par exemple
ce que je ne pense pas mais nous vivons
dans nos raisons d'en parler absurde que
tu as l'air complètement abruti voilà
comment je vais vivre
monsieur Berto vous êtes un homme
extrêmement cultivé extrêmement
intelligent
vous avez beaucoup de charme vous êtes
assez beau alors je voudrais vous poser
une question que les Français se posent
et que je me permets de poser à votre
place comment se fait-il qu'avec toutes
les qualités que vous avez et qui sont
indiscutables quand vous passez à la
télévision vous donnez la pression
d'avoir l'air complètement abruti tu
vois c'est pareil je te l'ai dit mais
j'ai enveloppé tout ça et je te l'ai je
te l'ai passé d'une certaine manière je
ne joue plus et puis alors il y a il y a
la conclusion et ça la conclusion dans
un débat politique c'est très important
vous avez vu que l'autre jour je dis
François Mitterrand Raymond Barre ont
été remarquables il faut le dire l'un et
l'autre dans les 5 minutes qu'ils
avaient chacun pour faire leur
conclusion et pourquoi tout simplement
pour une raison très simple c'est parce
que la conclusion c'est le seul moment
de ce débat qu'ils ont entièrement
appris par cœur ils le savent
parfaitement ils l'ont répété devant
leur glace le matin depuis 8 jours en se
rasant il la sauve comme on dit dans le
métier de comédien au rasoir absolument
partout alors là où c'est extraordinaire
c'est qu'il faut arriver à donner au
téléspectateurs l'impression que ce
texte qu'ils ont appris qu'ils sont en
train de l'inventer sur le moment et ça
c'est un acte de comédien et en même
temps c'est là où le meilleur ce métier
est fantastique est extraordinaire c'est
que il manie l'exploit sportif de rester
deux heures tendue nerveusement et le
métier de comédien il y a un mélange de
chaque niveau presque ah je sais pas moi
monter le Tourmalet en récitant le site
quoi c'est il y a un mélange de Poulidor
et Gérard Philipe dans ce métier là
alors je vais te montrer comment on fait
pour réinventer un texte qui est un
texte connu qu'on sait par cœur et
essayer de donner l'impression qu'on
avance ce que tu veux je sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'on va prendre une phrase
tout le monde un très beau texte à
Marseille par exemple alors voilà c'est
à moi c'est ma conclusion et je te parle
monsieur Bertaud
entendez-vous dans nos campagnes
mugir
je dirais c'est féroce soldat
ils viennent monsieur Berto
jusque dans nos bras
égorger nos fils et
permettez-moi de vous le dire
nos campagnes
sont plus larges
[Musique]